dans son allocution hier soir Emmanuel
Macron a voulu lancer un nouveau départ
il se donne 100 jours pour agir ces
priorités le travail la justice et
l'éducation mais a-t-il réussi à
convaincre faut-il entendre que on n'est
pas d'accord avec cette loi et que c'est
pas parce que il a des outils au pouvoir
qui lui permettent d'être autoritaire
que on le laissera devenir un dictateur
en fait
des manifestants qui estiment que le
chef de l'État les méprises comme ici à
Bordeaux on ne peut pas prendre le
risque de l'impuissance il faut se
mettre en danseuse et repartir relever
le museau et il y a d'autres pépites
celles qui suit et signé du ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin
les Français nous en veulent pour les
retraites mais ils l'ont avalé ce serait
faire erreur que de considérer que les
Français n'attendent le président de la
République que sur la question des
retraites parce que ce que les Français
nous disent au quotidien c'est que la
vie est chère c'est qu'ils ont du mal à
faire leurs courses qu'ils ont du mal à
faire le plan de naissance que la
facture de l'électricité a pu augmenter
pour eux ils nous disent aussi les
Français qui veulent retrouver une santé
comme avant système de santé comme avant
une école meilleure qu'avant qui veut
que ce soit pas toujours les mêmes qui
fassent les efforts pour les autres tous
ces sujets là qui sont importants je
vois pas comment on peut s'en sortir
pour être un peu crédible un peu
légitime je sais pas ce qu'on pense
Gérard mais je vois pas d'autres
solutions que c'est pas qu'on puisse
refaire des élections tous les enjeux
franchement
merci de votre réponse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il a été élu démocratiquement un
programme
Le Pen et il emportera
de lui dirige la politique du Pays-Bas
c'est n'importe quoi
[Musique]
on peut toujours compter sur la
photographe officielle du président la
petite souris de l'Elysée vous la
connaissez il s'agit de Soizig de la
moissonnière elle suit le président à la
trace elle est partout toujours présente
dans un coin pour imprimer l'image des
moments importants de toute façon hier
il ne pouvait je pense qu'il
est actuellement totalement inaudible
donc hier de toute façon il ne pouvait
rien dire d'accord et de ce point de vue
là il a rempli le contrat
il est possédé qu'est-ce que vous avez
dit Florian il est possible il est
possédé je rigole sors du corps Emmanuel
Macron sort du corps de cet homme 17
avril une journée avec Emmanuel Macron
on le voit avec la première ministre ici
Elisabeth borne lui dodo elle de face en
train de l'écouter sagement là il a
l'air de dicter son audition à droite
dans l'écran la chaîne BFM qui surveille
d'un œil il y a des élus ils ont été
élus ils font leur mandat on n'est pas
d'accord on jugera la prochaine fois
si entre deux le monde politique doit se
plier effectivement à toute pression de
la rue ou d'autres choses c'est mort
quand tu gouvernes contre ton peuple qui
s'exprime et 90 % contre la réforme
comment tu appelles ça c'est une
démocratie alors j'ai failli passer à
côté de ce petit reportage car soit
digue de la moissonnière m'a bloqué sur
Instagram ça c'est le compte ouvert en
revanche pour moi et pour toi Yann c'est
ça voilà accès à rien c'est le cas de
pas mal de journalistes de la rédaction
on oublie Macron on ferme les yeux un
président de la République qui se dit
être à la tête d'une république
démocratique qui continue à réformer le
pays contre 90% de la population qui
mobilisée qui s'exprime contre tous les
syndicats unis et uniques depuis des
décennies comment tu appelles ça vous
êtes en train de vous êtes en oui oui
française français mes chers
compatriotes les yeux des Français ont
regardé en bas à gauche c'est tout le
monde s'est demandé il y a des cadres
l'essentiel pourquoi elle est capte sur
le bureau mais à quoi sur les cadres si
plus de millions de Français ont suivi
final locution télévisée d'Emmanuel
Macron ces cadres retournés ont attiré
l'attention de nombreux téléspectateurs
rien de mystérieux puisque Soizic de la
moissonnière la photographie officielle
du Président de la République a partagé
une photo du bureau avec les cadres de
face
il s'agit de plusieurs clichés du
mariage du couple présidentiel ainsi
qu'un portrait de Charles de Gaulle un
cadeau offert par Jacques Chirac à
Emmanuel Macron lors de son élection en
2017 elle nous a bloqué donc du coup bah
on peut pas voir ce qu'il y a dans les
cadres en fin de l'enquête ils nous ont
eu nous ne serons jamais ce qu'il y a
dans les cadres à moins de créer un
compte en deux secondes un compte qui
s'appellerait je sais pas kikou c'est
encore nous puis regardez après son
allocution Emmanuel Macron s'est offert
une déambulation dans Paris La Croisée
un groupe de jeunes et accepté une
session karaoké improvisée sur un
champérinaire intitulé Le Refuge en
écoute
[Musique]
ces jeunes sont des membres du projet
quanto une application qui promet de
recenser compiler numérisé des champs
traditionnels et vous le voyez sur leur
site ils mettent en avant le soutien du
ministère de la Culture sauf que cette
association a fait l'objet d'une enquête
il y a quelques mois vous savez
peut-être au mois d'octobre le journal
Libération parlait d'une subvention de
40000 € du ministère alors que
l'application sur l'application
elle-même ont trouvé des champs du
Troisième Reich un des créateurs de la
plateforme serait même issue du guide
l'organisation étudiante d'extrême
droite cette amphithéâtre est à peine
reconnaissable des tags ont été faits
des bureaux jusqu'au plafond
des murs ont été détruits après 6
semaines d'occupation le bâtiment E de
la fac de Caen a été évacué hier matin
les dégâts sont estimés à plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros
le singe hurleur qui crie le plus fort
généralement il a les plus gros ou les
plus petits testicules du groupe
vous pouvez répéter j'ai pas entendu
c'est un singe hurleur voilà bon celui
qui crie le plus fort des dans les
stages hurleurs c'est celui qui a les
petites ou les grosses couilles en gros
c'est ça la question que vous est posée
on va dire les grosses couilles
les plus petites testicules depuis le 6
mars un collectif composé principalement
d'étudiants
occupés une nuitée jour le bâtiment il
entendait protester contre la réforme
des retraites et aussi contre la
précarité étudiante il ne comprend pas
leur expulsion
eux ils parlent de dégradation il parle
de tag nous on parle de dessin on parle
de réappropriation des lieux dans ce
lieu pendant un mois on a défini notre
façon de vivre c'est la définition la
plus absolue de la liberté